la sécheresse qui s'est installé en
france prend maintenant des proportions
extrêmement préoccupante
images spectaculaires avec ses rivières
comme la charente qui massent à certains
endroits qu'on peut la traverser à pied
le pyromane était un pompier
professionnel écroué hier soit aidé a
reconnu être à l'origine de cet départ
du feu dans le var
consternation dans leurs rangs des
pompiers professionnels hélène 15 ans
déborah saison des paroles disparu
depuis plus d'une semaine
elle se rendait à la fête foraine de
boulogne sur mer on les aurait vus
monter dans la voiture de deux jeunes
gens rencontrés en colonie de vacances
à cinq jours de l'évacuation des colons
israéliens de gaza certains se préparent
au départ dont ils font comme si de rien
n'était alors qu ariel sharon a
réaffirmé le maintien de son plan
athlétisme christine arron décroche la
médaille de bronze sur 200 m à helsinki
nous y reviendrons dans leur dernier
album des rolling stones critique
ouvertement la politique de george bush
et vous verrez que nous avons pu
rencontrer le leader du groupe mick
jagger
madame monsieur bonsoir avant de
développer ses titres destination
helsinki pour la médaille d'or médaille
d'or et oui la première de sciences
championnat que vient de remporter le
français ladji doucouré sur 110 m haies
il est vrai que ses performances tout au
long de l'année il avait déjà classé
parmi les favoris christophe duchiron
il était 19h45 à paris ou ne veut plus
aller au coeur de ladji doucouré avait
sonné qu'on leur numéro 5 le france avec
une grosse pancarte de favoris accrochés
dans le dos et deux favoris le
sympathique la diva se faire vainqueur
en 13 secondes et 07 100e pour pas grand
chose pour trois fois rien il devance
d'un souffle chinois liu xiang vouloir
numéro deux et le champion olympique en
2004 à athènes et l'américain allen
johnson espoirs plus que prometteur
ladji doucouré champion du monde du 110
mètres chez les cadets puis chez les
juniors dans cette discipline ô combien
technique
le voilà maintenant désormais champion
du monde chez les très grands
et nous retrouvons en direct delphine
qui tous nouveaux médaillés bonjour vous
nous entendez là dit le court n est ce
que vous nous entendez vous êtes en
direct sur france 2 vous nous entendez
alors il va avoir un micro ça y est il a
une oreillette je vous entends très bien
alors évidemment on vous félicite
journal évidemment vous êtes formidables
la première médaille d'or il faut
rappeler que le dernier qui avait gagné
ce sont 10 m et ladji doucouré cp guy
drut en 76 voix mais real c'est une
succession absolument inouïe c'est très
flatteur pour moi parce que voir guy
drut cet instinct grand homme du sport d
edf et bah si on compare à lui c'est
très très gentil alors vous aviez la
dernière fois chuté au en finale devant
d'avoir le chinois et c'est très
sensible a débattu c'est une belle
revanche
on va pas parler de revanche parce que
c'est pas du tout la même compétition
mais bon c'est toujours les mêmes
personnes donc c'est on va dire c'est
une belle deuxième course au maintien
mais c'est que les championnats du monde
ce pas les jeux mais c'est quand même
une très très grande compétition pour
nous donc je suis très très content
d'avoir franchi la ligne avant tout cela
vous avez aussi coup sous la barrière
des seize secondes
oui oui c'est la barre des 13 secondes
il ya quelques temps il ya un mois oui
mais l'objectif ici ce n'était pas de
décrocher un chrono dont je fêterai 0,7
quand même c'est je crois c'est ma
quatrième meilleur père mais le but est
aujourd'hui vraiment c'était d'arriver
avant tout le monde et montrer que que
début de la compétition j'étais bien et
qu avant la saison j'étais bien que j'ai
j'ai su repasser des barrières après
après les jeux vous êtes le seul à ras
bord et ses parterres quoi une médaille
d'or que tout n'est pas fini pour
l'instant je vous interromps reste pour
l'instant mais ce n'est pas fini
j'espère que que demain ça ira mieux
avec le relais et avec manuela qui
enfreignent en ce moment c'est vrai que
c'est la france
d'autres médailles en tout cas merci
d'avoir été avec nous et encore bravo
pour ce très beau résultat
merci de m'avoir accueilli coopagri mais
au revoir quant à christine arron allait
de nouveau en bronze dans une
pour ce cas là en partie menée dans la
finale du 200 m vous voyez christine
cayla évidemment en tête mais sur la
dernière ligne droite et bien c'est
l'américaine allyson felix qui a
remporté sept médailles et qui est
devenue championne donc à 19 ans voilà
pour ces toutes dernières informations
concernant les championnats du monde à
helsinki
revenons en france maintenant avec une
sécheresse qui persiste s'installer
oblige les pouvoirs publics à prendre
des mesures de restriction de plus en
plus sévères 68 départements sont
touchés dans les départements de la
charente où le niveau de la rivière est
par endroits extrêmement bas les
nouvelles mesures ont été prises
reportage nicolas lisez et si les prix
ten le sol est à peine l'humide
rocailleux et pourtant c'est bien le lit
de la charente un fleuve devrait
s'écouler mais par endroits comme ici
aujourd'hui c'est garde-pêche peuvent le
traverser à pied il le constate la
situation s'aggrave de jour en jour
regardez les berges que l'eau est en
train encore de baisser de se retirer
donc ça sèche petit à petit sur les
bords vous voyez bien il ya plus d'eau
très peu il n'y a plus de il ya plus de
courant donc bon c'est vraiment
dramatique quoi on peut pas je ne peux
pas dire plus quand je veux dire c'est
s'est jamais vu c'est la charente est à
son plus bas niveau ses affluents à sec
du coup les nappes souterraines à
proximité du fleuve ne se régénère pas
ces puits de captage par exemple il
alimente plusieurs villages 5000
habitants et la crainte ici c'est une
pénurie d'eau potable
notre inquiétude est que va quel va être
le niveau du fleuve charente dans un
mois ou deux mois
ici c'est très bon en général on a un à
deux mètres au dessus pas de pluie
annoncées dans les dix prochains jours
la question de l'approvisionnement en
eau pourrait rapidement se poser à
l'échelle du département
disons que ça pourrait aller jusqu'à 90
milles habitants ce qui est quand même
considérable et en zone rurale c'est à
dire des habitants
répartis sur une vaste zone ce qui
compliquerait l'alimentation en eau par
citerne ou par bouteille
si malheureusement on en arriver à ce
point dans les communes concernées
les habitants sont très sensibilisés au
problème on a toujours économiser l'eau
mais alors là on fait un corps un effort
supplémentaire et je crois que ce serait
très dur si en tourner le robinet et
qu'elle ne coulerait pas des mesures de
restriction ont été prises dès demain
sauf dérogation interdiction totale
d'irriguer les cultures au bord de la
méditerranée sur les plages mais aussi
en ville les municipalités applique une
politique de restriction mais aussi de
prévention exemple à six fours les
plages dans le var françois jullien
pieds-noirs et christophe la rocca de
l'eau à volonté pour barboter d'un côté
aucune goutte de l'autre pour se doucher
restrictions oblige les touristes de
six-fours doivent s'adapter après la
meignanne nous est ici un point de vue
qui retourne pas faire des sacrifices de
temps en temps les chanceux pourront
toujours se des salles et dans leur
piscine mais interdiction de la vidanger
et les jardins c'est de nuit qu'il faut
les arroser en cas de flagrant délit
1500 euros d'amendé en cachette vous
n'avez pas arroser votre cabanon pour
six fours l'été c'est 80 mille touristes
deux fois plus que d'habitants la
consommation d'eau explose les touristes
sont un peu plus consommateurs ils sont
moins sensibles qu'elles aient les
jeunes et initie à l'aspect très
précieux de l'eau puisque on en a manqué
pendant des décennies au lavage
automatique
c'est là que c'est le seul endroit
autorisé pour laver sa voiture qu'on
pense aussi aux gens du pays pas
bordeaux c'est pas évident on consomme
beaucoup d'eau en bouteilles d'une noce
ratio power donc ne serait ce pour la
voiture les gens autorisés en effet un
peu trop mais dans les campings de
six-fours l'eau ne manque pas
le campeur peut s'adonner à son sport
favori la vaisselle mais ici comme le
pastis l'eau est à consommer avec
modération
pourquoi vous mettez si peu d'eau là
mais les restrictions finalement peu
d'importance car à six fours
cela fait longtemps que l'on sait vivre
d'amour et de peu d'eau fraîche
certaines industries consomme aussi
beaucoup d'eau comme la fabrication de
pâte à papier du pays quelques années
les secteurs fait des efforts exemple
avec la chapelle d'arbres est entreprise
qui a dépensé 12 millions d'euros pour
économiser le reportage à grand couronne
en seine maritime
edouard bergeon et patrice à cherré la
scène une ressource en eau quasi
inépuisable pour cette papeterie
assoiffés
pour autant le temps du gaspillage est
révolu à la chapelle darblay depuis 15
ans ont fait des efforts à commencer par
des contrôles pas question de laisser
passer une anomalie habituels autour de
90 80 mètres cubes par heure
le fait de l'affiché pas nous permet
d'intervenir rapidement et de réparer la
corde de la dépendance est aujourd'hui
en plus d'être vigilante lusine a
investi 12 millions d'euros pour
recycler dépolluer et assainir l'eau le
pompage grâce à des variateurs la
papeterie prélève uniquement ce dont
elle a besoin
le recyclage l'usiné utilise l'eau en
circuit fermé en projet l'installation
de filtres supplémentaires pour pouvoir
réutiliser les eaux usées traitées pour
l'instant rejetée à la scène mais un
quart de la consommation globale
s'échappera toujours dans l'atmosphère
sous forme de vapeur et volonté d'abord
économiques indispensables mais
également et surtout écologique en 15
ans la quantité d'eau pour produire une
tonne de papier a été divisé par six
le but est de diviser encore par deux
ses besoins d'ici 2010 depuis la
sécheresse de 1976 l'état oblige les
papetiers comme le reste de l'industrie
à faire des économies
la drire par ailleurs dans une démarche
de progrès continu agis de telle sorte
que les prélèvements d'eau diminuent ce
qu'a fait la chapelle darblay en
particulier avec de nouveaux systèmes de
gestion des fonds malgré ses efforts
pour produire 1000 tonnes de papier la
chapelle darblay a besoin chaque jour
vingt-quatre mille mètres cube d'eau
soit l'équivalent de 16 millions de
bouteilles d'eau minérale
du côté des particuliers de plus en plus
de familles prennent conscience qu'il
faut construire des maisons plus
écologique
alors après les économies d'énergie
voici les économies d'eau avec notamment
un récupérateur des eaux de pluie une
idée qui a été reprise par la mairie à
rueil malmaison reportage brno timsit et
christian galley la fierté de louis
michaud bled c'est sa dernière
trouvaille au fond de son jardin
la pluie tombe sur le toit en haut là et
elle redescend dans le nucléaire là à
les filtrer
allez fais ici l'eau de pluie se déverse
ensuite dans les cuves qui peuvent
recueillir jusqu'à 400 litres il n'y a
plus qu'à se servir
avec ce système depuis deux ans ce
retraité arrose son potager sans compter
il peut assouvir sa passion du jardinage
tout en réalisant des économies d'eau en
ces temps de sécheresse
un acte citoyen s'est pas beaucoup un
seul fait de 400 litres
c'est quand même c'est quand même si
tout le monde faisait ça avec 400 litres
qu'après beaucoup d'eau a une idée qui
fait école
la mairie de reuil malmaison a décidé de
s'en inspirer et de généraliser les
récupérateurs d'eau de pluie donc toute
la commune pendant les dix écoles de
réveil qui possède agenda écoles dès la
rentrée sera installé ce système de
récupération d'eau ça sera la même eau
sauf qu'elle viendra de la pluie au lieu
de devenir du robinet l'objectif sera
donc également éducatif pour apprendre
plus petits à économiser l'eau pour
prendre dès le plus jeune âge les bons
réflexes
c'est un pompier professionnel qui a
finalement été identifié comme le
pyromane à l'origine des sept départs de
feu et c'est lui qui était chargé
d'informer les journalistes justement de
départ de feu et des moyens engagés pour
les combattre il a été écroué à la
prison de draguignan il risque entre 10
et 15 ans de prison
caroline gauthier épaules de genève
le sergent-chef gauthier vivait seule
dans cette maison un incendie se déclare
mardi chez lui
pompiers et gendarmes découvrent un
jardin en broussaille des mégots un peu
partout du charbon de bois inquiétant
chez un pompier arrêté il avoue être un
incendiaire se trouve ça aberrant de la
part d'un pompier professionnel de faire
des choses comme ça déjà bon sa
propriété pas tellement entretenu a dû
fouiller partout
je pense qu'il devrait déjà montrer
l'exemple pour pour les champs
environnants être propre net pour cogner
pas le fait qu'ils prêtent jean yves
gauthier a reconnu être à l'origine de
six incendies depuis 2003 le dernier
remonte aux premiers route juste au
dessus de sa maison en guise
d'explication devant le juge il a évoqué
des pulsions sous l'emprise de l'alcool
consterné les pompiers du var ne veulent
rien entendre
il me manque le plus c'est que dernière
en main il a pas bien longtemps on a
perdu nos camarades incertaine au
camarade alpha mais donc que ce soit un
pompier au fort plus aberrant encore le
sergent-chef gauthier s'occuper de la
communication des pompiers varois
c'est lui qui lançait par exemple ses
messages de prévention sur une radio
locale
un incendie de forêt lien dans votre
direction il existe et efficace pour se
protéger
ayez les bons réflexes les journalistes
qui le côtoyaient n'ont jamais douté de
lui aucun soupçon franchement aucun
soupçon et on ne peut pas imaginer qu'il
ait fait un acte commun comme celui ci
quoi et pourtant la justice se demande
aujourd'hui si le sergent-chef gauthier
n'est pas à l'origine d'autres incendies
ces dernières années dans le var fort
heureusement ce genre de cas est
extrêmement rare la sélection des
pompiers professionnels et rigoureuse et
la pyromanie est une défiance difficile
à détecter explications anouk burel et
christophe widemann
des pompiers pyromanes l'histoire en a
connu très peu de professionnels surtout
des volontaires dans les deux cas il
passe des examens médicaux avant d'être
engagé un test sur leur personnalité
voir s'engager comme un pied puis on
pourrait décider sur ce trouble du
comportement
on va pas essayer de sa engagé comme
pompier justement pour mettre le feu
pour l'instant je ne mets jamais vu dans
ma carrière été 2003 dans les roues
l'incendiaire est un jeune pompier
volontaire de 19 ans il avoue avoir mis
le feu plusieurs fois pour toucher des
primes d'intervention c'est une des
raisons qui motivent les pompiers
incendiaires
parfois ils agissent même en groupe
comme à echirolles en 1982 ces cas là ne
relève pas de la psychiatrie la
pyromanie oui par exemple à vittel
sébastien roubinet involontaire de 25
ans il a allumé les feux et participer
aux interventions ces malades du feu
sont difficiles à détecter longtemps
avant leur passage à l'acte et pourtant
les pompiers rejette fréquemment des
candidats pour raisons psychologiques
les gens qui ne sont vraiment pas que
les dragons sont relativement faciles à
détecter néanmoins c'est pas du sang
pour sang ni même
ni même pour un psychiatre incendiaires
pyromane les sanctions encourues sont
toujours très lourdes 15 ans ils ont
fait courir des risques corporels et la
perpétuité s'il ya mort d'homme dans
l'enceinte
et puis on apprend à l'instant que à
boulogne-sur-mer
hélène et deborah 15 16 ans viennent
d'être retrouvées elles avaient disparu
samedi dernier on se rendant à la fête
foraine elle serait en ce moment même au
commissariat de police nous y
reviendrons évidemment sur cette
information qui nous parvenir avant la
fin de ce journal
pour la première fois un djihadiste
francophone s'est exprimé sur une chaîne
de télévision de dubaï
c'est ce que révèlent nos confrères du
figaro les extraits proviennent d'une
vidéo de propagande tourné par al qaïda
en afghanistan et l'inconnu qui
s'expriment n'a pas encore été
identifiée par paris bernard lebrun et
romain clément nouvelle mais en fait
c'est sans fin sans limite
al qaïda menace désormais en français et
c'est une première
ce document de propagande venus
d'afghanistan confiante par l'image
la théorie d'une filière française de
recrutement al-qaïda attirons corps de
jeunes djihadistes francophone des
combattants de la guerre sainte qui avec
les talibans dans les montagnes afghanes
attaquent les forces américains on sait
qu'il ya des dizaines de deux jeunes
français en malt de d'action qu'ils ont
été
sur ce champ de bataille et on sait
qu'il ya une quarantaine en groupe qui
se trouvent en irak
il est il francophones ou français d'où
vient-il
comment est il arrivé la dst et dgse les
services secrets français enquêtent
depuis le 5 août une certitude cette
cassette vidéo de propagande intitulé
opération contre lacroix recueillis à
islamabad au pakistan est formellement
daté par l'attaqué d'un hélicoptère
américain
les papiers du soldat montré à la caméra
le prouve il est effectivement mort en
afghanistan le 28 juin dernier avec 17
de ses camarades
et puis après la décision de l'iran de
reprendre en effet la conversion de
l'uranium en dépit des avertissements de
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique le président américain george
bush a confirmé ce soir qu'il n'excluait
pas le recours à la force pour dissuader
l'iran donc de reprendre la conversion
d'uranium en israël malgré les
protestations des colons malgré les
menaces des nationalistes le retrait des
israéliens de gaza devrait être terminé
dans les 5 jours qui viennent et déjà
les donateurs rachète à prix dans les
serres des colons pour les donner à
l'autorité palestinienne quant au
logement ils seront tous rageuse et et
pourtant certains n'arrivent toujours
pas à croire à ce départ sur place
martin laroche joubert et gilles jacquet
l'aube se lève sur les dernières heures
de travail de ses ouvriers palestiniens
chez les colons de la bande de gaza
évacuée la semaine prochaine au
checkpoint que les contrôles habituels
de moins en moins deux palestiniens ont
obtenu ces dernières années
l'autorisation de franchir ces barrages
une routine qui va disparaître avec le
départ de ces colons venus les chercher
pour la dernière fois sans doute je suis
content que ça n'aille bien que je
n'aurai plus de travail ou 17 ouvriers
palestiniens
c'est bien pour la prochaine génération
mais aujourd'hui côté colons l'amertume
se mêle à la tristesse je suis
bouleversée c'est tout ce que je peux
vous dire
principales activités ici l'agriculture
en sert à vie il emmène les ouvriers
palestiniens qu'il fait travailler
depuis longtemps j'ai vécu ici pendant
25 ans est emballé 25 ans de vie c'est
vraiment terrible
avis a vendu ses terres à la banque
mondiale ils les faits désherber par ses
ouvriers
une remise en état pour en principe de
futurs agriculteurs palestiniens
il partira avant que l'armée ne l'y
force ça ne l'empêché pas d'en avoir
gros sur le coeur
le gouvernement nous n'avons pas reçu de
véritables aides pour nous les
agriculteurs il contraire mais ce n'est
pas vrai autre réaction celle d'abraham
et de i'm not il cultive des tomates en
serre mais ils ont décidé eux de
continuer à travailler comme si
l'évacuation ne devez jamais arrivé vous
pensez qu'on est si fou que ça des
israéliens on va investir de l'argent du
travail pour que cette abandonné je vous
ai dit que nous on est des gens croyants
on croit que dieu
il va faire un miracle et que nous on va
rester alors pour pas perdre et la
saison en implanter je reste je suis sûr
qu'on va gagner
dieu nous a promis cette chère nous
vaquons dans cette colonie très
religieuse
il ne leur reste plus long en effet qu'à
prier dieu les shabaks commence ce soir
les airs sacrés du repos pour les juifs
il risque d'être le dernier ici à gauche
katif et ce auprès de londres une partie
du personnel qui s'étaient mis en grève
hier a repris le travail certains vols
pourraient redécollé à partir de 20h 21h
près de 70 mille passagers ont été
bloqués itso l aéroport international le
plus fréquenté au monde
laurent bouvier et dominique marault tél
sur le tarmac des dizaines d'avions aux
couleurs de british airways immobilisé
depuis 24 heures sur le parking du
terminal 4 de l'aéroport des shows des
milliers de passagers de british airways
bloqués par la grève d'une partie du
personnel au sol
la compagnie certains sont là deux
cuisinières et commence à en avoir assez
ça a été l'abandon total hier on s'est
débrouillé tout seul à minuit et demi on
heureusement s'est regroupée à plusieurs
à plusieurs français et on a un an et
rés et puis après on s'est débrouillé
c'est par solidarité avec les employés
de pnj une société de restauration
aérienne licencié cette semaine par leur
employeur que certains bagagistes et
conducteurs de bus de british airways
ont cessé le travail immédiatement la
compagnie a annulé tous ses vols au
départ dix chevaux entraînant pagaille
perturbations et attentes pour près de
70 mille passagers c'est une véritable
tragédie pour notre compagnie et pour
nos clients qui ont travaillé dur toute
l'année pour partir en vacances
nous avons été entraînés dans ce conflit
et c'est notre compagnie et nos
passagers qui en font les frais je
voudrais m'excuser auprès d'eux cet
après midi un accord a été trouvé entre
la compagnie et ses personnels
quelques avions devrait décoller dans la
soirée mais même en cas de reprise du
travail donc des vols ce soir la
situation ne va pas s'arranger
rapidement selon un responsable de
l'aéroport
il faudra plusieurs jours avant que la
situation ne redevienne normale à new
york le prix du pétrole a atteint pour
la première fois 67,10 dollars pour un
baril de brut une flambée des prix qui
est aussi alimentée par une série de
pannes dans les raffineries américaines
alors que la demande de pétrole est au
plus fort de l'année aux états unis avec
un pic de consommation dû aux départs en
vacances des américains en voiture et
pour la première fois on redoute une
pénurie d'essence conséquence les
voitures hybrides c'est à dire essence +
électricité deviennent follement
tendance reportage à new york pascal
golomer et tristan le bras à première
vue sa voiture n'a rien d'exceptionnel
pourtant david bloch n'est pas peu fier
d'avoir été l'un des premiers acheteurs
de ce modèle hybride
c'était en 2000 hybride parce qu'il
fonctionne à la fois à l'essence et à
l'électricité
une électricité que produit la voiture
elle-même en freinant l'idéal pour la
conduite en ville c'est le moteur qui
choisit sa source d'énergie en fonction
de la conduite la facture à la pompe
s'en ressent
je dois faire le plein comme n'importe
quel autre conducteur ce n'est pas un
véhicule électrique que je dois à
recharger c'est une voiture comme une
autre la différence c'est que je vais
beaucoup plus loin avec un faible 1,5
litre aux cent quand la voiture
américaine standard dépasse allègrement
les quinze litres
pas étonnant à l'heure où le prix du
pétrole s'envolent que toyota compte
vendre 100 mille hybride cette année aux
états unis
certes cela représente à peine 1 % du
marché mais on en parle beaucoup et les
constructeurs américains d'abord
sceptiques se joignent peu à peu au
mouvement
ford propose désormais l'un de ces 4 4
en version hybride
mais pour 5000 euros de plus tout de
même ce une nouvelle technologie c'est
toujours plus cher mais les prix vont
baisser et à terme ce sera un bon choix
pour le consommateur comme pour
l'environnement
et c'est au nom de la protection de
l'environnement que san francisco met en
circulation des taxis hybrides new york
va suivre dans quelques mois
plusieurs états offrant même des
réductions d'impôts à tout nouveau
propriétaire en termes de pollution
atmosphérique de réchauffement de la
planète de dépendance énergétique nous
devons trouver des solutions
l'apparition de ce type de véhicule est
un pas dans la bonne direction
quel que soit le nombre de voitures
vendues les modèles hybrides marque en
tout cas un tournant
consommer moins d'essence devient chic
et tendance aux états unis c'est déjà
une révolution et en france les
véhicules 4 4
eux connaissent de plus en plus de
succès notamment dans le très haut de
gamme se sont pourtant ceux qui
consomment le plus et qui circulent
exclusivement en ville reportage au 22e
salon de val d'isère céline crespy et
antonin broutards elle grant
elle grimpe les ventes de 4,4 des ventes
qui ont été multipliées par 5 en 10 ans
au salon du tout-terrain de val d'isère
on a de quoi avoir le sourire
sur les six premiers mois de l'année
2005 le 4-4 explose le marché est à + 22
% de progression c'est c'est fabuleux
sur l'année 2004 déjà on était à plus 15
pourtant la réputation du 4 4 a été
plusieurs fois éclaboussé trop polluant
trop gourmands en carburant
j'irai qu'en moyenne il doit faire en
gardant tous les cycles à peu près 12
litres 2 800 km sur route ça consomme en
moyenne 10 onces d'être des
consommations ici sous-évalué et quand
on les titille les constructeurs ont
toujours le même argument la
consommation d'un 4 4 est comparable à
celle d'une berline
il n'empêche qu'à la pompe le prix du
pétrole flambe et la note est salée de
litres effectivement 73 ans on est à la
montagne du tableau
m
ça fait mal du coup les constructeurs
cherchent des carburants verts comme
l'hydrogène
l'icsp elle donc plus la confiance qui
permet en fait de rouler propre
c'est l'énergie effectivement de
l'avenir c'est la génération après les
hybrides
mais pour l'heure selon lagence de
l'environnement rouler en 4 4 contribuer
trois fois plus au réchauffement de la
planète que rouler en berline
je vous le disais il ya quelques
instants à boulogne-sur-mer les deux
jeunes filles hélène et deborah 15 et 16
ans viennent à l'instant d'être
retrouvée avait disparu samedi alors
qu'elles se rendaient à une fête foraine
de boulogne je vous propose d'écouter
cette cause pendante laurence de l'homme
qui doit nous parvenir
hélas les démographes vient
effectivement d'être retrouvé par la
brigade des mineurs de boulogne-sur-mer
elle rentrait chez elle lorsque la
police est arrivée alertée
vraisemblablement par un témoin qui les
avait aperçus dans la ville à 500 mètres
du commissariat
elles sont actuellement interrogé par
les enquêteurs qui leur font subir
également des examens médicaux et de
jeune fille avait disparu samedi dernier
elle avait été vue pour la dernière fois
à la fête foraine de boulogne sur mer on
ne sait toujours pas où elles sont sales
et pendant ces six jours mais elles sont
vivantes et l'a priori en bonne santé
bonne nouvelle donc pour des parents qui
était très inquiet stéphane kélian le
chausseur de l'ex français qui emploie
cent quarante-trois personnes à romans
dans la drôme a déposé son bilan la
société qui avait déjà connu difficulté
avait été racheté par le groupe smalto
la maison ne serait compétitive ni sur
les prix ni sur la production c'est ce
que laisse entendre la direction
françois dalle l'ancien pdg de l'oréal
est décédé aujourd'hui à genève à 87 ans
entré en 43 dans les fonds monsavon
françois dalle avait restructuré
l'entreprise pour faire de l'oréal
leader mondial des cosmétiques
proche de l'ancien président françois
mitterrand françois dalle avait quitté
le groupe en 1984 le yacht de luxe qui
s'était échoué mardi sur un rocher au
large des côtes de sagone en corse a
coulé cet après midi avant que les
opérations de renflouement n'ai pu avoir
le long de 48 m ce yacht été depuis son
échouage à moitié immergé le capitaine
britannique du navire était mise en
examen poste de genève
idem darcos ces remous au loin c'est le
lait jeunes qui sont au large de la
plage de sagone aujourd'hui la
méditerranée a forci l'épave n'a pas
résisté à ces vagues puissantes qui ont
envoyé par le fond
cet après midi le bateau britannique
échoué ici depuis mardi dernier
14h50 et on s'est aperçu que le bateau
avait coulé enfin vu l'état de la mer
c'était évident que elle n'est pas
restée longtemps ancré sur les récifs
comme ça à 16h le navire de la marine
nationale l'arago est arrivé sur sow il
a rejoint l'ailette
ce remorqueur de haute mer aujourd'hui
leur travail s'annonce bien plus
compliqué l'épave repose maintenant par
deux mètres de fond après avoir heurté
le récif de saint joseph
pourtant indiqué sur toutes les cartes
marines la mission de ces bateaux de
surveillance est maintenant de prévenir
toute pollution mère devenait dur est un
humoriste d'évolution de la mer devenait
dur nous prendrions des dispositions
complémentaires tels que par exemple le
prélèvement du gasoil dans le souk
directement des protections d'ailleurs
encerclent déjà les par le capitaine du
bateau britannique quant à lui été mises
en examen cet après-midi pour mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui et pollution
de l'espace maritime et rejets
d'hydrocarbures
les salariés de l'industrie chimique et
métallurgique même si son protégé ne
sont pas à l'abri des maladies
professionnelles les risques toxiques
existe c'est ce qu'affirme une étude du
ministère du travail voyez ce témoignage
d'un homme qui manipulait justement des
solvants aromatiques vanessa avoué et
michel robin ce cellulaire beaucoup pour
les industries de exemple fabrication
d'encre ce sont les produits qu'on
utilise quotidiennement sans protections
adaptées
ce salarié à manipuler des solvants
aromatiques six heures par jour quinze
mois durant assez pour perdre le sens de
l'odorat
plus ça allait plus je voyais que
il y avait vraiment un problème aux
produits utilisés et donc j'en faisais
part au responsable de production et le
responsable de production n'en prenez
pas compte sept employés étaient
victimes d'une maladie dite
professionnelle souvent difficile à
prouver
donc a recensé mais selon une étude du
ministère du travail
trois cent soixante six mille salariés
sont exposés à des produits toxiques
pouvant être nocifs pour la santé dans
le secteur des industries métallurgiques
et chimiques dans 70 % des cas le risque
est dit maîtriser
encore faut-il que l'employeur détecte
le danger un produit dont les effets se
manifestent immédiatement je pense par
exemple à un produit comme un acide ou
une base qui va vous brûlez la sanction
est immédiate donc là tout le monde à
l'idée que le risque existe par contre
quand on est face à un produit qui peut
éventuellement déclencher des cancers
dans 30 ans il est vrai qu'on peut être
tenté de se dire bon à 30 ans est loin
et puisque et puis est-ce qu'on en est
bien sûr jusqu'à l'année dernière les
salariés des secteurs exposés devait
passer deux visites médicales par un
paradoxe aujourd'hui une seule est
obligatoire c'est un non sens quand on
dit que le dernièrement que le
gouvernement va prendre des dispositions
alors qu'ils ont pris un décret qui va à
contre sens justement de ce ton souhait
de ce qu'on revendique les plus touchées
sont aussi les plus modestes
deux personnes sur trois sont des
ouvriers amm auprès de parer une
policière a fini par avouer qu'elle
avait agressé une grand mère et son
petit fils de 4 ans la gardienne de la
paix de 27 ans a été interpellé à son
commissariat où elle travaille et
mathias hillion élise mais n'at il y a
dix - derrière ses murs une grand-mère
et son petit-fils été sauvagement
agressé à coups de couteau
coups de poing coups de chaise la
personne âgée est sérieusement blessée
au bras
le garçon de 4 ans sombre dans le coma
l'agresseur cagoule et prend la fuite
dix mois plus tard il est identifié
grâce à son adn retrouvé sur un couteau
étonnement des enquêteurs c'est une
gardienne de la paix la jeune femme de
27 ans bien noté par sa hiérarchie a été
arrêté sur son lieu de travail mardi
dernier au commissariat de meaux ses
collègues ne comprennent pas son geste
apparemment prémédité
elle était à l'opposé de 2,2 de toute
violence est donc effectif effectivement
le khat ont fait le parallèle avec
l'agression vis-à-vis de cette dame et
vis-à-vis de cet enfant dans notre
société on les protège et justement un
policier plus que jamais doit protéger
ce genre de personne la gardienne de la
paix n'était pas en service le jour de
l'agression compagne du père du petit
garçon
elle affirme qu'elle ne supportait pas
d'être rejeté par sa belle-famille un
mobile qui ne convainc pas les
enquêteurs la jeune femme a été mise en
examen et écrouée pour beaucoup ce
week-end et 15 autres signifie la fin
des vacances alors avant de repartir
demain parfois on savoir les derniers
instants et l'on commence à ranger
reportage à narbonne plage au camping
des falaises frédéric montaillé fédéric
d'en céder celle du dernier jour il
plane un parfum de mystère
on ignore qui des hommes ou des femmes a
le plus la main l'eponge surtout dans la
famille godfrain
à regarder les femmes ont choisi leur
camp
après la vaisselle direction la plage
avec les enfants pendant ce temps les
arrière-grands-parents se livrent un
déménagement ou d'envergure et au moment
où on remballe ou orange c'est encore
les vacances
oui oui c'est encore les vacances
toujours les vacances des vacances
vignerons demain depuis 16 ans le
spécialiste du rangement des friteuses
c'est jacky godfrain y ranger sa façon
et
cela revient à celui qui ressort tout et
il sait comment s'est rangé à 500 mètres
de là les filles et des enfants
barbotent mais demain la grande aurélie
quittera justin sa complice de vacances
c'est l'heure des grandes promesses
l'appellera même
devenus des copines avis et c'est fêter
une confusion sans fil est foncièrement
descend encore frappé et beaucoup de
garçons qui sont venus vous draguez
olena de brive retour au camping
après trois heures d'effort
l'emplacement 183 est prêt pour le grand
départ demain direction château thierry
900 km de route ce soir l'ultime
apéritif le dernier plaisir des vacances
et nous retrouverons bien sûr demain la
famille godfrain dans certaines régions
très prisé de france d'autres touristes
sont devenus des habitués le sud ouest
accueille ainsi chaque année des
britanniques des hollandais dans le
périgord un million cinq cent mille
touristes étrangers viennent en vacances
chaque année
emmanuel lambert et chloé le compte ce
matin à monpazier
c'est jour de marché sur la place
médiévale des centaines de personnes se
pressent on regarde on touche en doute
les productions locales
ici comme partout dans la région un
acheteur sur deux est étranger
j'adore l'atmosphère ici toutes les
odeurs ses couleurs les choses que l'on
voit c'est vraiment différent de
l'angleterre depuis une vingtaine
d'années anglais hollandais belges se
sont épris du périgord alors les
producteurs se débrouillent comme ils
peuvent pour vanter leurs produits
on a vu se débrouiller valait pas grand
chance puis bon on savait tout ce qui
est mangée by boissons on arrive comme
ça qu'on frappe ici c'est pareil on ne
parle pas tellement français ce camping
est tenu par des hollandais pour des
hollandais 90 % de la clientèle vient
des pays-bas
c'est plus facile pour nos enfants pour
se faire des amis et nous on ne parle
pas bien français
c'est peu ceux-là et très bien très bien
mon ami très bien eux aussi ils trouvent
la france très bien voici la famille
henshaw touristes il ya quelques années
ils ont décidé de traverser la manche
définitivement pour s'installer ici
ils ont entièrement restauré une
ancienne grange en ruine tout là toute
la journée et bien sûr avec l'action ici
séquence est tranquille on aime aussi
gastronomie douceur de vivre
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à
vouloir s'installer en france dans le
périgord six acheteurs de maisons sur 10
viennent de l'étranger à très loin de là
enfin prises au sieda dax 5 jours de
fête où l'on pratique la course de
vaches sa musique des bandas avec à
chaque jour son thème mais hier c'était
l'ouverture environ 700 mille visiteurs
sont attendus dans cette ville qui
compte habituellement 22 mille habitants
au tour d'horizon des meilleures
adresses david badié et dan harmon armes
à dax l'hôtel splendid c'est
l'institution de la feria tout le monde
s'y pressent pour une table en terrasse
pour n'y est une chambre ou pas c'est là
qu'il faut être vu car c'est ici que
loge les matadors de la corrida c'est un
hôtel classé art déco effectivement il
ya beaucoup beaucoup d'histoires
notamment en matière de tauromachie qui
sont passés dans l'établissement l'hôtel
abrite aussi des artistes que peuvent
rencontrer les visiteurs lorraine fin
sur des planches darren marquée par les
coups de cornes des taureaux
c'est plus une brûlure wasquehal et les
coups de cornes sont tellement vite
dehors la fête est lancé dax 22 mille
habitants accueille 700 milles festa
hier il y a aussi des gladiateurs car la
ville fait remonter ces férias à
l'époque romain aujourd'hui les
gladiateurs ce sont les écarteurs
landais éviter les cornes au dernier
moment volé au dessus
cette tauromachie pratiquée seulement
dans les landes est toujours le
spectacle d'ouverture des arènes de dax
espagnol
c'est peut être plus réservé à des gens
unifiée mais je crois que l'ordre public
la nuit dernière on a fait beaucoup de
coucou à la caméra pour montrer qu'on
est bien sous revue les techniques
employées par certains
il n'y a aucun doute c'est le but de la
soirée alors là j'ose amené dans un
endroit très secret jean-françois mengel
lui connaît les moindres recoins de dax
son endroit secret est situé sous les
arènes
les bénévoles de la feria s'y retrouve
des endroits de privilégier ceux qui
aiment bien qu'ils sont un peu
tauromaches donc plutôt dans les
peignant
notre musique fait de bons temps libre
dégâts le torero lui et couchent tôt fin
d'après midi départ de l'hôtel splendid
pour la première corrida des férias la
nuit des étoiles 2005 trois nuits pour
découvrir et reconnaître des noms qui
font rêver
grande ourse petit ours voie lactée et
train du berger alors n'hésitez pas à
découvrir le ciel
allongez vous et laissez vous happer par
l'immensité de l'univers avant même la
sortie prévue le 5 septembre du nouvel
album des stones appelée big bang un
titre qui suscite déjà quelques
commentaires il met directement en cause
les néo conservateurs proches de george
bush
abdellah mostefa a pu rencontrer en
exclusivité mexicaine regarder toronto
hier soir il ya ceux dont dieu qui ce
mic et dans la salle un millier de
penhars
la tournée n'a pas commencé les stones
ne font que rodez leurs nouvelles
chansons
la première date officielle se fera aux
états unis ce sera le 21 août à boston à
quelques encablures de washington il y à
un morceau qui risque de faire grincer
quelques dents
il s'intitule sweet neocon mon cher
néoconservateurs il n'est franchement
pas tendre avec les républicains
devraient dresser tout le monde comprend
doit immédiatement mais c'est pas vrai
c'est pas vraiment les choses très
professionnel george bush pas visé mick
pratique fait il la langue de bois
même si le nom du président n'est jamais
cité on ne peut s'empêcher de penser à
lui
en outre l'activité bien sûr car avec
les stones zh le rock'n'roll finit
toujours par en prendre au chaudron
voici le troisième festival lyrique en
plein air de l'été après aix et orange
ça se passe un sens c'est près de
poitiers avec la bohème de puccini une
représentation que nous présente laurent
10 et jean-jacques le garrec de zone on
veut qu'ils se déclarent leur flamme
très classique pour un opéra en
l'occurrence la bohème de puccini
non ici c'est le cadre plutôt qui sort
de l'ordinaire
il ya une ambiance vraiment spécial ce
sont plein air surtout à la tombée de la
nuit comme ça il ya une atmosphère qui
se crée même le soin différents dans la
vraie vie ici c'est un site
archéologique un amphithéâtre gallo
romain du 1er siècle qui prend les airs
de partie de campagne pour l'occasion
planaire oblige celui qui donne le là
pour ce soir c'est le vent encore un peu
trop fort quelques dizaines de minutes
avant le spectacle en avisant voilà pour
le suspense pour l'histoire la bohème
c'est la vie insouciante des artistes
parisiens à la fin du dix neuvième
siècle à montmartre ou au quartier latin
leur pauvreté et évidemment les femmes
de leur vie
jamais un théâtre romain en ruine on
n'était pas sûr que on entendrait ici
c'est parfait la qualité du son
impeccable et la nuit si près tout est
fini
pour trois soirs l'opéra s'est invité
dans la nature alors un juste retour la
nature elle aussi a voulu faire un clin
d'oeil à l'opéra avec ce papillon nuit
en anglais butterfly pas loin de madame
butterfly titre du plus célèbre opéra de
puccini
ainsi se termine ce journal à suivre la
météo de patrice drevet et puis le poids
route avec julien pascal 29,50 pj 00h40
journal de l'ani françois boullot n'est
pas moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain dès 13h excellente
soirée sur france 2